[Music]
deanna is with us in knoxville to start
this hour off hi deanna how are you
i'm doing all right i'm tickled to be on
the show with you guys well we're
honored to have you how can we help so
my husband and i have been handed a
pickle
he's been he's being sued for a debt
that he co-signed with his now ex-wife
and she was supposed to refinance it as
part of their divorce she never did
now they're coming to him for it
we understand legally there's there's
not a lot we can do i mean he did sign
for it
but we were wondering if there was there
was anything negotiating just anything
that we don't have to pay the full the
full bet
what is this on
um it was if i understand everything
correctly it was a car that was repo
oh that's wonderful how long ago was the
car i know it's great
um i think
probably six years back uh we've been
married for three and it was at least a
couple years before then if i understand
it
the repo was
while they were still married
yes okay so they they had they owned a
car together and their car got repo'ed
okay yeah he he he co-signed a car for
her no he didn't co-sign his wife they
bought a car together
he just bought a car in his car right
yeah his car got repoed it happened to
be the one she drove but he got repo'ed
while he was married before
and now and the repo was six years ago
if i understand the timeline it's kind
of blurry to me obviously this is all
before we got together and got married
did he just hope this was going to go
away
it was something that she was supposed
to take care of in the divorce so it was
and of course she up and disappeared
last week or she's somewhere in nebraska
running from her debt so
it's working and so um
watch out nebraska look out nebraska
here she comes the uh
uh
okay so did you actually get served
lawsuit papers
and it was sent to um his old house that
we had sold to his daughter his daughter
let us know what is it
a letter or the uh yeah from from the
sheriff i'm assuming it is
well
i'm not assuming anything that's what
i'm trying to figure out do you have the
paper in front of you
i i don't
he has pictures of it on his phone it
was it wasn't us we live in tennessee
he's from indiana so this is
all over the country right now okay all
right yeah so let's just stop a second
okay number one i doubt you've actually
been sued
he he might have gotten a notice saying
they were going to send something to the
sheriff but if they were going to sue
him
from a six-year-old
repossession deficit they would have
done it a long time ago
it's very unusual to get sued on a
six-year-old house
okay well it's possible they did it's
possible someone sold this debt okay
so either way here's what's gonna go
down okay you get in touch with the
holder of the debt
one of two things has happened either it
is the original holder of the debt or
they have sold the bad debt to a bad
debt buyer
there are people there are companies
that buy old bad debt
and then try to collect on it and they
usually pla pay around a nickel on the
dollar
for it do you have any idea how much
money they're asking for
the paperwork that was sent initially
said eight grand when he called them
yesterday they said 12 on the phone and
i said oh hell no we're not doing we're
not doing any we're not doing any of
this
okay
so here and here because here's the
thing let's just say it's ten thousand
dollars they probably paid five hundred
dollars for this debt if they bought it
okay that's what they got in it so
anything they get above 500 is a profit
for them
okay right now the uh
it's very difficult to collect a debt
across state lines
okay for them to execute service on you
in tennessee and actually start getting
money from you
using a lawsuit to do that is is it's
very expensive for them so they're not
going to do it
the probability is very high they're not
going to do it so this is all about
posturing
and bullying the schoolyard tactics not
about legal realities okay so they
either paid around 500 for this debt
or they're the original holder and just
put put those shoes on for a second it's
been six years if someone owed you money
for six years anything you could get out
of them you would call yourself having
one right
right all of this translates to you can
settle this for around 20 cents on the
dollar it's gonna cost you two grand
okay
i can breathe with that yeah and so call
them and offer them
seventeen hundred and forty three
dollars
as settlement in full and tell them
that's your calculation as to what his
part actually is after all these years
and that's what we're able to do any
more than that and we're just we don't
want to talk to you go ahead and sue and
do whatever it is you want to do because
we're not going to pay it
okay and with all of that between the
two of us he's he's a lot more um
easygoing about it i'm more of the
bulldog do i it's not they won't talk to
you you're not on the debt that's what i
wanted that's why i want to make sure
he's gonna have to wear big boy pants so
you're gonna have to like uh pull his
hair or
twist his ear or something get him a
little riled up before he calls him
i can do that i can do that and deanna i
want to challenge something from this
point forward okay
yeah the world did not hand you all a
pickle
you spoke as though this like hail hail
storm sat over your house
this is your husband signed up for this
and we
understand that okay so yeah this is
y'alls moving forward okay so let's
change this change the tone this is mr
easy going didn't take care of business
yeah yeah
this was before he knew better we went
yeah i don't know better way so i can't
be mad at him
yeah you go okay that's good so yeah so
get him riled up and here's the thing
okay
start at 1743 you're gonna settle
somewhere a little over two thousand
dollars give or take they will take that
it's going to take go ahead and count
them uh between five and ten arguments
they're not conversations they're
arguments
okay because you're dealing with an
idiot in a cubicle 500 miles away who
has a really horrible job cleaning
septic tanks is better than collecting
on old debt
that's fair okay
he he's he really talks nasty to people
all day long and then has to go home and
kiss his children with that same mouth
it's awful
and so that's the guy you're talking to
and so you have to argue with this guy
five to ten different times and it will
land between 1743 start with that number
and it'll end above two thousand get it
in writing before you send the money in
writing in writing in writing or don't
give them any money that they accept
that as settlement in full
and then do not give them electronic
access to your checking account send
them a prepaid debit card or a wire
do not give them electronic access to
the checking account and get it in
writing five to ten conversations this
is an argument go